connected we're playing this game okay
it's a cute little game you may have
heard of it it's called the last of us
okay [ __ ] um and okay well you know
let's just let's just get into it ok
there's no need to dead old at all it's
your boy psychobabble don't see here
look behind back [ __ ] now let me just
make sure these subtitles are on here
okay okay and [ __ ] where the [ __ ] is
that game i sucked i was like always
sucking hit and is anyone now gore
definitely on show tag pop-ups okay
let's do this let's do this the last of
us a new game yes yes that's correct I'm
normal good good good um new say data
yes yes okay yeah I would like to say
here thank you um thank you uh I taken
so long that much has happened to save
on okay okay I guess we'll just jump
right into it you know baby sorry sorry
that cursor that's gonna awkward there
we go there you oh [ __ ] is that dose as
bestest nobody knows you need a real
qualified guy test it as I'd always tell
my tenants Jays I'm all riot their dicks
most water yeah I got good good I'd love
playing in my dark apartment what people
far away behind my brick walls I just I
love that ok okay um hey this dust it's
a like so loading what's going on here
Oh stops loading is great
a naughty dog game I like I'm not like a
naughty uh hello princess thanks are
sleeping we hope you enjoyed your stay
Oh Tommy Tommy listen to me he's the
contractor he's the contractor ok I
can't lose this job I understand well
let's talk about this in the morning ok
we'll talk about it in the more you know
hey hey baby I'm Nate work huh are you
still doing that slate crud what time is
it it's way past your bedtime still
today honey please not hurt how do not
have the energy for this here this is
your birthday I get
you kept complaining the back broken
watch oh so I figured you know that's
pretty kid nike yes I mean it's all
right but you know I honey who's just
you're my eyes but I don't work I think
it's stuck it's not what no no no oh
haha where did you get the money for
this drugs I sell hardcore drugs oh good
we started helping out with the mortgage
that yeah you know is uh asleep again
Sheba jabbers or just sleeps all day
she's taking that kid I got it I got it
sometimes you got to take it
hey gals may I gals bad as when is back
that t-rex what is that antelope and as
taxing I don't think that I'm in us its
gaming time that can I can I again if I
can get a job get a job hi YouTube
channel like a mini is calling hello
Sarah honey I need to get your daddy on
the phone uncle tell me what what time
is it I need to talk to your dad now
this up sad uncle Tommy hello okay you
sit down this what was that all about
that is this right here triangle it okay
I forgot to give this to him [ __ ] and I
for the page you're not a fossil yeah hi
your earth day dear dad let's say you
know roundabouts music on it too you
practically despise the movies I like
and yet somehow you still managed to be
the best at every yet how do you throw
that and I birth I pops up Sarah can't
get okay and anything anything else here
now let's get to skip the [ __ ] out of
here trying LS match and this
PlayStation controllers funny [ __ ] let
me tell you soon your ass in your papa
hey papi papi it's gone out in here is
this the [ __ ] I've been sitting here
my whole life alright so what's the
newspaper ad matin spikes an area
hospital dude mysterious in fact three
hundred percent oh shut
okay well that's for adults oh I don't
get it done daddy daddy daddy it's your
son Margaret it's your son Margaret you
in here somehow connected to the nation
resume how are you we've received
reports that victims afflicted with the
infection she's super nice aggression
there seems to be some emotion coming
from buck huh I gang was that yeah what
I was I've got got got can't get get his
army [ __ ] hey talkies ha papi what is
going on and on now
okay Oh dad where aren't you here's his
phone set eight missed calls Tommy Tommy
pull me oh no wait i SAT up blackberry
and no one day he's got no second Bell
you know how long day I'm not surprised
honest answer someone likes horses here
handing out there
where is he hmm here you are sir are you
okay yeah anyone come in here get the
job come here don't go near the doors
just just stand back there okay dad
you're kind of freaking me out what's
going on it's the Cooper side so many
ride with him I think they're sick
they're getting that dick sucked holly
[ __ ] let's cut the [ __ ] out of me Jimmy
dad come here [ __ ] why pencil this the
windows there is something bad going on
you've got to get here do you understand
me yeah saying it i get to-- come on you
have any idea what's going on out there
I got some lotion oh [ __ ] you got blood
all over you any but let's just get out
of here get on that bad I the people and
save your lost their minds we just
please go hello the parasite or
something out Sam's you gonna tell me
what happened [ __ ] that's a good game
hey Sarah how you holding up honey ah
[ __ ] all right I guess gu hear us on
the radio yeah sure thing
nothing out there
we're doing great news man would shut up
I say where to go it's not gonna pack
until roadblocks on the highway okay
maybe travis county 77
they say him on your dead probably a lot
fellas one family all mangled inside
their house oh [ __ ] right I'm sorry oh
yeah I my cat I my cat I can't be
hearing this okay first time this
happened they got no clue we had the
only town your burst their stingers just
the sound
these Coast West comes through [ __ ]
that's Louis's farm
lohan so much made it up that batch that
I can I ain't not he did it what are you
think no of course how do you know have
five seconds to people in the city we're
good didn't kill me work in the city
it's right fine all right not Santa that
chasing ah sorry thank you think you're
doing keep driving I got a kid joe so do
we we have room I keep rubbing out stuff
sacks s sack you see I see someone else
to come along
that's how i always think somebody elsea
come along possibly we know that's
[ __ ] up yeah if we woulda never mother
had the same game idea electicon awesome
we could just backtrack kick ass yeah
we're just gonna watch this oh holy [ __ ]
yeah that is that what come on people
move what are they running from are they
gonna [ __ ] again to try get away from
it we can't stop your zucchini [ __ ]
classroom go ahead up there behind me to
their day hold on go Cat Cat
what are they right uh yeah yeah okay ah
my lives hey hey
you back me you back
okay i'm squaring up I'm scoring up for
about oh [ __ ] huh hey sighs I better get
Sonya betta goetta for you get got hell
I'm saying I got a person thank you sir
yeah I'm here baby okay cool come here
here what is it my leg hurts how bad
we're gonna need to run keep us safe
cool bit k passe back I'm running oh
[ __ ] i'm running
keep that way so people don't look Sarah
look at amazing yeah okay
hey I don't get out oh this guy we got a
publish guy [ __ ] the people in a [ __ ]
way get the [ __ ] out the way okay and
yeah let's go oh my god now let's yell
we're almost there we're almost there
life is over highness sure there's
people hop in I'll up the place I closer
to our vets
yeah he's gonna be fine now we can leave
him it's easy as 123 leavings easiest
thing in the world
who's the guy yelling outside I can hear
ya I am [ __ ] Roseanne don't sound like
Tommy we're safe we're safe hey we need
help prop it's my dog lick her legs grow
right there ok we're not sick I've got a
couple of civilians on the outer
perimeter please advise daddy what about
ya ready you deciding go background ok
sir there's a little girl but yes sir
somebody we've just been through hell
okay we just did what's gone is that how
that's all right oh no sir ah Sarah move
me Sarah no no baby don't know see me
you know this work may be okay baby stay
with me that's a mac attack you come on
Eli let me get it take it off of me nope
I'm sure would make it thats Sarah for
you always gonna sleep I always got a
site and I like many of them I'll tell
is by combat I think up yeah okay I
guess it I got oh my god don't know oh
no now look back james out price
Sarah that's the last of us well he's
the last of us I guess the number of
confirmed deaths has passed 200 the
governor has called a state of emergency
thank you to hundreds of bodies lined
streets panic spread worldwide after
release report from the world open
spacious showed that the latest
vaccination tests have failed but the
bureaucrats have a power we can finally
take the necessary steps Los Angeles is
now the latest city to be placed under
marshal sure residents are required to
report to their designated for whites
have continued for a third consecutive
day and winter rations are at an
all-time low
a group calling themselves the fireflies
have claimed responsibility for both
attacks their public charter calls for
the return of all branches of government
illustrations broke out following the
execution of six more alleged fireflies
feel rise with us remember when you're
lost in the darkness look for the light
filling entire life dips out for her
Amish